[Music]
in sense of humor for the wind news Wow
so bored submitted by will you go to
homecoming with me which one [ __ ] yeah
yeah which one I do it just crash your
homecoming randomly I didn't go to my
home for me I'll go to yours I'd look
like the creepy pedophile uncle but I'm
down wear your cape if you wear your
cape you won't oh yeah you'd like the
school mascot a new study says that
funny guys give the best orgasms orgasms
what that's not true that's not true all
right then oh my god you know why
because funny people are giving ya joy
like we like to give orgasms yes but
just don't be funny when you're trying
to be sexy I came inside do you bring me
no where is this Study Center this new
study published in socio affective
neuroscience and psychology that's it so
they had a hundred and three single
women which is a small pool in my
opinion yeah there's very small very
small I would just take the green salt
they answered a series of questions so
anyway this series of questions that the
answer to revealed how often women
experience orgasms as a result of sexual
intercourse was related to their
partners income self-confidence and how
attractive he was and then the orgasm
intensity was also related to how
attracted they were to their partners
mix it
so these women were asking questions
they seemed to kind of rate the
characteristics that they sought after
the most so number one was humor
number two is attractiveness number
three is creativity number four was
emotional wealth warmth sorry oh I was
like emotional well I'm actually
emotionally poor then because I'm not
too emotional emotional warmth five was
faithfulness and fix is body odor
pleasantness
oh [ __ ] where's the company also girls
don't even give a [ __ ] about your
hygiene no we care but not it's not like
on their personality is not belonging
you mean funny is number one yeah being
funny
but in like humor is kind of subjective
is very yeah so that's the match I guess
your humor exactly okay
like Three Stooges type of girl then you
probably go for a guy that like whackies
overthrown heads and stuff morning
morning
punk yeah so they were just saying like
you know if you have a really good sense
of humor you're super hot you're
creative yeah oh that's just so hard
[Music]
uber hot creative because if you're
super funny you don't pick your body
seriously Holm is this is hardly
groundbreaking in my opinion yeah like
this is like I would assume that that
women would think that and I wouldn't
waste time researching this like how the
focus has benefit the world at all like
I don't understand why people spend so
much of geeky guys funded the study now
that I learn how guys always want to
know how girls work
I mean it's not hard to figure out one
than one it's exactly the type of guy
you don't have a problem we want to be
it's like you see James Bond on the
screen right I want to be that guy
that's pretty much exactly what women
won it's not hard to figure it out but
it's not though because we want a funny
guy and James Bond's not funny plus
funny Austin Powers
yeah there you go that's funny he's so
funny James Bond yeah and are you Randy
baby all the time yeah yeah it's not
hard for you
second gentleman is Austin Powers outfit
the same one that Jamie Foxx were in
Django
prop Department is Sheriff blue it's
blue with the early thing like how did
you all just think I got awesome powers
right now I thought it was orange for
some reason that's a ramen dumber I
gotta look this up the first one I feel
like in the first movie he wore blue
with the like they both dressed like
Prince yeah yeah I don't know dude a a
lot of funny guys um I think the
funniest one ever dated actually did
give me the best orgasms oh those circus
clowns yes they always beat the [ __ ] up
[Music]
that's a pretty funny guy though he is
pretty funny but so he's funny but then
when he doesn't need to be funny so
he'll say [ __ ] like that's the problem I
don't know like you'll just say [ __ ]
when it's like so if you're trying to
have like sexy time talk like you're
trying to be like sexy right and like
freaky or whatever then he'll come with
a weird joke that I'm like no I think
we're just used to it by now
yeah that's like it just I'll just say
[ __ ] afterward so I'm like oh you know
that thing or whatever like maybe not
let's not do that we all know somebody
this dude's like such a goofy guy I'll
tell you what he's after play this fool
told me that he hooked up with a tinder
date and when he was out in LA she said
that he got upset at her he was telling
me this story like I was supposed to
agree with them so she was on top and
this will just go to her titty and goes
yeah he goes like that
and it goes like yeah man shoot say she
wasn't a moose I want a girl who doesn't
have a sense of humor I was like bro
that's pretty bad though geo came the
hardest she's ever come into walk
sideways into the room baby no we've
gotten better okay we're really good now
we're really good what do you want
tonight how much to be an Alaskan crab
come on that's how you roll plays other
animals they're furries can we be a
little more romantic like a flamingo
today we're just gonna stand on one leg
when I said it with the one leg does
anyone here role play no it's not a word
yeah I don't think we can like I wanted
to share something because I wanted to
see venules because I feel like we don't
role playing I don't think we can we're
not capable of this you can't it's hard
to lose ourselves into it yeah like she
wants me to Magic Mike dance for her I'm
like wow look at you
I want anyone in here for like two
seconds and I was like even in those two
seconds
just get drunk so just give it to her
but then I'm like I'm like where's
where's my real stripper dad you didn't
ask no the reason why I wanted you to do
it those because he's obsessive Magic
Mike 1v the movies awesome at the chick
flick that sounds it's a chick flick
that's not a chick flick though you
really look at Magic Mike and I'm now
I'm getting some movie stuff but it's
not a mess it's not a chick flick even
close
you're like buckets like a [ __ ]
10-minute just app in [ __ ] pulling on
it so I'm talking about the [ __ ]
story okay if not it's not a Matthew
McConaughey story question though are
you are you playing
Ginuwine pony you're telling me that the
biggest movie snob in our whole group in
the world to me I don't know weird it's
also directed by a director that's not a
studio director do you know who directed
in it No Steven Soderbergh one of the
one Ocean's eleven guy yeah that is
weird
the movie snob movie snobs are people
who are people who don't want to listen
to any other anybody else's opinion
they're so stuck on one thing even
though with you guys not with me okay
well that's every relation about all you
guys he agrees with you and like in
front of you but he goes what he's like
gave it's [ __ ] stupid I can't believe
he loves that movie guys make you [ __ ]
hard he asked about the role plain not
anything that's like us
have you ever tear what they know what
exactly is role-playing then when you
pretend to be others something else is
when you put your Uncle Sam outfit
I Pierre bergé fantasize about Uncle Sam
no like role-playing is also like
scenario like you can say like oh we're
like in the 1920s I'm like this rich
white girl's daughter but you're a
Chinese ro I'm a Chinese railroad worker
and you're not supposed to [ __ ] me you
go into the back you get overalls in
pursuit of course so I know how you so
I'm [ __ ] up and I want more [ __ ]
that's like aggressive and then he feels
bad there was that one time I spanked
you and they started crying
[Laughter]
that copy off guard she start bleeding
out her mouth what if Bart doesn't get
the point she's like I want you to be
aggressive he just starts [ __ ] more
Asian you wanted it to her right [ __ ]
face kills me what up all my positive
people I want to hear your thoughts put
it in the comments below because if
you're negative shut the hell up and go
drink some raid please but if you're
very positive leave it in the comments
below
for the last video over here
[Music]